hey folks
hope everybody is
doing well
huh
been a bit of a
rollercoaster day or so
hello meg hey carowind
ms wicked
wolf cara homebody
good to see folks john
ah
i'm glad folks like it yeah i'm
i'm quite happy with it
lots of love to jin she does
wonderful work
um
so yeah uh
i'll say something can't remember what
it was
that might be that might be my mood for
the day oh i remember
so reminder
um
for anyone who's new
to the group um the only thing that uh
guarantees i do try and keep up with the
chat but the only thing that guarantees
that i will see uh an answer respond or
read your comment or question is a super
chat you also get a heart from me for
that unless you are a member of the
council of geeks patreon in which case
there is a patreon on uh there is a
discord
channel for
uh questions to be addressed on the
patreon and the discord is a patreon
exclusive perk there we go it looks
longer yeah it's because um it's
sort of um it's not as much of the curl
going on right now
so
oh
i'm an idiot
i'm a [ __ ]
who
couldn't be bothered to uh
set up the dang
microphone
yeah
let me see
make sure
okay
folks hear me okay now
uh
i can't believe it did that
suppose i should
go over everything again
okay so uh the
i do try and keep up with the chat uh
the
uh one thing that'll guarantee that i
read your commoner question if you are
not a patreon and in the
council of geeks discord which is the
patreon exclusive perk is to make use of
the super chats i will absolutely i
guarantee you address your question or
comment in that way and you also get a
heart from me for doing so
okay there we go
uh
opening my hydration module now oh
that's a good way to think about it i
like that i like that a lot
in ottawa you're a very intelligent
person you're just a human that can make
mistakes ah yeah
okay i
i suppose if you're going to insist on
being
nice and [ __ ]
if you had brains and beauty it wouldn't
be fair
[Laughter]
oh i can always count on you to
uh
keep me in my place meg i appreciate
that
uh
where do you think doctor who would be
as a franchise if eccleston stayed for
another series but it means attendant
never comes in i'm
mr mr zaki boy i'm a terrible person to
ask that i'm
awful i am awful about trying to even
wrap my head around those kinds of
hypotheticals because my brain rebels
when i try i basically there's a huge
part of my brain that just goes why are
you even trying thinking about this it's
not the case it'll never be the case
stop wasting energy so especially in a
live situation where i can't like sit
down and force myself to think about
that for a while i really can't tackle
that kind of question
uh my friend asked me a fun question if
you could choose any of the modern
iterations of the master to have a story
against the 11th doctor who'd you choose
oddly minus sasha dewan oh um
okay so
so a master specifically to take on 11.
i mean i want to say the war master but
just because i really want wanted more
derek jacoby um
but i'm not sure that would actually
be my pick i
you know i think i'm actually gonna go
with you i think i'd probably go with
dejuan as well
i think i think that would have been a
good fit
i'm drinking a much deserved
caffeine-free pepsi which probably
sounds gross but it's my jam i mean like
i don't drink soda at all so i don't
even like think oh that's gross i just
think i have no idea what it tastes like
because i just don't like the entire
range of beverages
ah
pretty sure that's alcohol it is water
and you cannot prove otherwise
uh how would doctor who and in my mind
doctor who ends with whatever is the
current incarnation of the doctor
going to susan and retiring to just be
her grandfather or grandmother or
grandparent or whatever
um
they are at that point that in my mind
is how you end doctor who
uh
oh
the supreme court i have i have a
feeling that's gonna come up
in here i'm not i'm not quite ready to
run headlong into that wall yet but i'm
sure it'll come up again
eliza i have not yet seen the newest
house episodes because so
um my kiddos my kiddo is currently at
her mother's she'll be back here later
this week um
she told me flat out i'm not wait
because we watched the show together she
told me flat out i am not waiting
until i'm with you to watch this but you
also better not watch it without me so
she's seen it i'm not allowed to until
she's over here so
i will
but i haven't yet
uh
excuse me
did i see the dreamworks movie uh the
bad guys i haven't i was gonna ask my
kiddo if she's already seen it and if
she hasn't that might take her this
weekend
i recently discovered
i recently discovered something about
myself my pronouns are now she they oh
jamie
that's great i'm happy for you
uh
weird question what is the weirdest
fandom i've ever seen
i don't
know how to judge a fandom as weird
because like a fandom is shaped by
whatever the thing they're a fan of is
so like
you'd have to think the original thing
was weird to think the fandom was weird
but then like it's just a natural
extension of it
so it feels weird to call it
weird
at least to me because in my mind like a
weird fandom would be a fandom that
has a distinct disconnect from the thing
that they're fans of but i haven't
personally encountered that and as like
a mass group thing there are like
splendor groups within fandoms that
are weird disconnects but that's
that's leaning more into the toxic
fandom issue and that's a different
thing and i've gone rambling on about
this um despite the fact that i don't
actually have an answer hey
have i seen heart stopper on netflix yet
if so would you do a review of it i have
not
you are about the third person to ask
and uh i don't know what that is
still having trouble hearing me uh is
that
any um
okay so
is that
just is it just you carowind or is
anyone else having trouble hearing me
can i get a quick check in on that
uh
so folks let me know
how
um well you can audio's fine
loud and clear okay
can hear just fine okay
all right i want to make sure because we
had the issues earlier
um
voltron's the most toxic i've never
really had an encounter with the voltron
um phantom i can tell you the fandom
that caught me most off guard
um
with how volatile they are is the fans
of the show inside number nine
it's why i stopped watching that because
i watched the first series thought a
couple of episodes were really good
thought some weren't very good at all
and apparently thought one of the sacred
cow episodes of the whole freaking show
was not good and um
i got a
lot of really deep
uh hate thrown at those reviews uh it's
part of why i have not uh
watched any more of it because i don't
ever want to talk about it again i've
had that happen with movies too
like fans of in bruges still find my
review where i basically call it out for
being pretentious which it really is and
like years later they're still leaving
like well you're just dumb and you don't
get it comments it's like
what
uh
you put an unflattering review about
about something no matter what it is
somewhere
there are fans of that thing who will
find that review and crap on you
uh
i think war master best pairs with nine
since i'm pretty sure rtd wrote him with
the idea that this was the version nine
went against and or fought with well i
really would have liked to seen
warmaster go against the word doctor but
we never got that
may the fourth be with you oh that's
right i always forget about that until
it happens and then i see it's trending
on twitter
uh it's a new lgbtq show based off a
book series about a schoolboy finding
love with another boy that goes through
the
am i gay phase but it's beautifully
written
i don't like high school
stuff i just don't
it doesn't mean it's not good
i'm just kind of like
i
like maybe it's good but i
i would much rather find
representation in a
a format and a genre i actually like
rather than venturing to something that
i just
don't
i don't know
there are no weird fandoms only only
weird fans
and a weird fan as a gatekeeper or one
that can take things beyond just normal
enjoyment i mean yeah i guess that makes
sense
i can vouch that the lord of the rings
phantom has no sense of humor i mean the
biggest lord of the rings fan i know has
a sense of humor but i think that speaks
more to her benefit than anything about
the about the fandom
do i have a squishmallow plushie i do
not have any squishmallows
um
in contrast to marvel with peter and mj
how come dc mostly
leave clark and lois alone with the
exception of the new 52 they never tried
to derail it
or erase it from canon
um i wonder why well because of how
embedded it is the thing is like
clark has always been with lois like
always since the very beginning the idea
of superman not having a lois lane
kind of
breaks the character she's too
fundamental like a comparison to mj
doesn't work
having superman without a lois lane is
like having a peter without an aunt may
like it's
more deeply into and like i know they've
killed on may or they should have killed
on may multiple times but i mean like
never having her at any point it's too
integral to the core of what the
character is to just scrap you can
reinvent it and adjust it all you want
but like it kind of needs to be there
same with lois whereas mj was peter's
third girlfriend in the comics and the
marriage was hastily thrown together
that said
they really shouldn't have dissolved it
that was very stupid
excuse me
uh
do i prefer simpsons or futurama
futurama just because you know it ended
or as simpsons i don't remember the last
season i saw
sorry you got hate from the inside
number niners uh shockingly it was
announced today there's gonna be an
american version but pemberton and shear
smith are only producing it oh that
won't last a full season
uh
severance had a subplot of two mature
men falling up oh i did wanna i didn't
wanna check severance i think i'm still
on my free trial for
apple tv that's on apple tv right
i might check that
i have two squishmallows i know i wasn't
ass but my love is real
i don't doubt it
um
have you ever seen a movie where your
action where your reaction was i'm angry
because this movie wasted my time
dead man and neon demon leap to mind
i want my time
back
have you uh
heard redacted and what do you think of
the trans representation i have not
heard it yet so i have no opinion
uh
magic the gathering phantom was
problematic for a long time maybe it
still is i haven't planned in ages well
i know that uh official magic the
gathering tournaments have now invoked a
rule that you can be disqualified um
from a match for uh deliberately
misgendering
your opponent
um
so
you know
hey that's a good rule to put in place
but b the fact that they have to make it
an official rule probably says something
not so good
uh first timer to your streams oh
welcome dallas i love your very
informative educational shorts on short
videos on lgbtq plus stuff oppression
and representation in the media uh thank
you very much i do need to get some more
shorts out there i haven't done a short
in a little while
show us the hair okay
it's
like the issue is the direction i have
to turn i'm turning to read the chat
like it doesn't give you the the color
in the hair so there it is there we go
uh might have been asked previously uh
uh but favorite lgbtq plus
superhero um
[Music]
huh
i'm trying to think um i mean batwoman's
the easy go-to except i haven't looked
at her stuff
from new 52 or beyond so i don't know
if they completely botched her
after that there aren't that many
superheroes that i stuck with long term
even the ones that i like so
i heard futurama's coming back it better
not
oh crap i did hear about that
oh i scrubbed that from my mind
because there was a pay dispute with
john dimaggio
that got sorted ah
crap
it ended so good just leave it alone
oh uh
supreme omega
thank you for uh the membership greatly
appreciate it mike
mikerson oh my god i can talk michael
anderson doyle
member three months but i've always been
a rabble rouser and i love that hair
viewer ah thank you very much
uh what's my favorite one of todd's one
hit wonders and train records episodes i
find my i think the train records i've
re-listened to the most is probably his
one on paula uh which was
um
oh
god
i can't i can't think of his first name
all of a sudden
but thick the blurred lines guy
um i keep thinking of alan thicke but
that's his dad
robin there we go robin thicke robin
thinks episode paula as for one hit
wonderland
hmm
i don't know
there are a lot of good ones there
um
honestly i don't know if it's my
favorite but the one that might have
been the most interesting was actually
the one of the more recent ones he did
the one uh on
uh love grows with where my rosemary
goes that was actually quite an
interesting one
i'm playing a pride
festival and i can't wait ah that's
great
killian murphy is doctor doom
maybe
uh what i ever do on video and wicked
being a two-part movie no i don't care
enough to make a video miss wicked wolf
we kind of go through this you uh yeah
like
i care about
theater to a certain degree but i'm not
a theater nut and i definitely don't
care about film adaptations of plays i
think it's a bad idea 99 times out of a
hundred the fact that they're bringing
into two movies i don't
like i have an opinion and i gave it
last time you asked me that but i don't
care enough to make a video on it
ah
you're right they do look bigger in the
instagram post
so for people who don't know
on the it wasn't the council geeks it
was the viral wild instagram
the picture i posted
about my hair was one that i uh was
actually a selfie that i took
with um
uh with with ginge who who
did my hair and my
my boobs look huge in that picture
and i noted that in the caption
favorite public domain superhero i don't
know who's in the public domain uh zorro
probably is the shadow in public domain
yet
i feel like he might be soon if he isn't
if he isn't yet
i don't know
uh
fisheye lends that pic
it's not quite that extreme but it's it
um
uh
fun fact the longest indian television
series had a total of 3 238 episodes so
far that's not bad
uh
i graduated from university today happy
graduation congratulations there
excuse me
take me on episode was outrageous aha is
by no means a one-hit wonder i mean
that's frequently brought up in his
things because sometimes he has to
acknowledge well they had another hit
but it barely qualified as a hit
sometimes it's um you know i'm doing
this thing on the hit they're known for
here but they had a ton of other hits
elsewhere in the world and sometimes
it's a case of yes technically they had
more hits but
this is the one this is the only thing
anybody remembers so i'm counting it
anyway he usually he's usually good
about acknowledging when things are kind
of an exception
uh
is the biggest lord of the rings fans
you know jessie gender by any chance
actually no
john uh
she is a very big lord of the rings fan
but no she's not the biggest lord of the
rings fan i know
next doctor prediction none don't do
them i'm very bad at that
uh my whole thing with theater into film
is uh
and this is especially with musicals
that a massive part of what makes
several shows work is the live audience
experience straight plays maybe
i mean well yeah especially with
musicals because the thing is a big part
of what you know even if there isn't
like a lot of audience interaction like
there is with something like say cats
there's still an inherent problem
because um
the a lot of what's impressive
about it
is knowing you're watching it live
dancing especially
like dance sequences or big chorus
numbers
or you know even the big spectacle shows
like phantom or wicked they're
impressive because they're on a scale
you don't expect to see on a stage but
it's a scale that is super standard for
movies there's nothing special about
seeing that scale on film that's what
films do
so yeah it's weird did he cover kung fu
fighting he did
he did
um
jodi whitaker wants lydia west to be the
next doctor i
do not know who that is
mr zaki boy that's your third time
answering exactly your third time asking
that exact same question
i already tried to explain that i'm
really not a good person to ask that
kind of thing my brain doesn't work that
way i can't do that kind of hypothetical
please don't ask again
that's three times you've asked me that
same question and i addressed it the
first time as much as i'm going to
uh lydia west from it's a sin oh
oh okay
oh yeah
oh that could work i mean i still want
joe martin but i've accepted that that
isn't happening
um
i don't know if you already said this
somewhere but are you going to watch uh
andor talk about the legend of korra
no
no to both
uh nancy gross thank you so much
uh have you seen gentleman jack
uh saran jones doctor's wife uh tardis
plays 18th century landed gentry lesbian
uh first super chat yay me yes marie i i
have not seen it i have heard of it and
the premise is very intriguing but no i
have not had the time
um
i saw the curious incidents of the dog
in the night time on friday and loved it
simple staging was so effective don't
know that one
actually been listening to the andy
circus reading
of the lord of the rings books and makes
them so easy to engage and absorb oh
yeah i bet he does a great
job what are your thoughts on downton
abbey it's a show that exists that i
don't watch there's my thoughts
uh
my dog just jumped on my couch and
flopped on my big belly she wants hugs
and kisses as all dogs deserve
simply for nature of them being dogs
michael b jordan for the next doctor no
no
i don't think anybody who isn't from the
british isles should be the doctor i've
said that before
yes rocky horror translated well into
film there's an exception king and i
also adapted well like some do
um chicago adapted very well partly
because the film actually added a layer
that the stage show doesn't have
um
but
i have a hard time thinking of too many
modern
musicals that would adapt well you know
given
just what is standard for film now
by the way moon knight i'm enjoying moon
night um
i really wish there was more than one
episode left because i feel like
for everything they've
brought in
um they
really need more than one episode to
properly explore so i'm nervous about
the last one
it's been rumored that rtd is going to
reboot the doctor upon taking over how
would you feel about that
i think that would be incredibly stupid
i've done an entire video about why
there's no need to ever reboot it i
don't think he would do that
i give no credence to that rumor
whatsoever irish doctor yeah sure irish
doctor go for it that's scottish why not
uh
yes uh those are mostly classic
hollywood examples yeah yeah exactly
the curious incident of dog in the night
is a holmes reference
um
but the but they do nothing in the night
homes yes that was the curious incident
okay
oh
mike's excited for strange oh um yes i
gotta figure out when i'm gonna get to
see it i got to sort that out
but yeah i'm looking forward to that one
doctor who has had soft reboots before
every regeneration is practically a soft
reboot that's not what i'm talking about
when and that's generally not what other
people talk about when they talk about
rebooting the show
like and i i can virtually guarantee you
that the people spreading the rumor that
he's gonna reboot it are the exact same
people who went not my doctor and hey
chris chibnall and want everything that
happened expunged from canon they would
rather see everything erased than
have that stand i can almost guarantee
you that's where that nonsense started
any particular reason why you won't
watch it i recall you saying you thought
you were going to connect more with
legend accord than with last airbender
well um
mostly because
i didn't finish last airbender
because
i realized i didn't care
and while i suspected maybe i would
connect with legend of korra more pretty
much everything i've ever seen or read
says
uh avatar's better
and
i didn't like avatar enough to keep
going
so yeah i've got no incentive
like i get it throw it on the pile of if
somebody pays me i'll watch it but other
than that no
did i have a pet goldfish growing up
briefly
i had two
that did not last long
oh i never think of ten scottish because
he didn't use his accent yeah
uh
my kitty likes hanging out on the second
shelf of our coffee table
uh
you could have any superpower what would
it be shape-shifting
same as every other trans person
[Laughter]
what's a director that has a varying
degree of quality in their filmography
i think of m night shyamalan well most
of the ones with the most variable
quality are generally going to be what
you can what are termed journeymen uh
directors who um
don't necessarily have a distinctive
style in
generally tend to only be as good as the
scripts that they get
um but if you're asking
directors like who are more auteurs and
have very identifiable and distinct
styles but who are very up and down
i could probably think of some um
have i stopped and thought about it i
don't have any off the top of my head
though
uh
after watching the classic siri blues
classic series blue ray collections and
revisiting stories i grew up with i
think doctor who would benefit from
scaling down the scope of the stories
and explore character development i
don't disagree
echoey
oh oh no so wait that's in response to
someone hold on
can't tell if i'm
if i've got an echo going or if
see you can't put a word like echo in
the chat without explaining because i
don't know if that's directed at me or
if you're talking about something else
completely
my superpower would be telepathy so i
could make annoying people and my work
shut the hell up well that would be mind
control not telepathy
uh telepathy actually means that you
could hear them even when they aren't
talking i think you might need to
rethink that one
did you ever watch the fan film
uh echoes end by confused opposed no i
actually don't engage with a lot of fan
um
content not because like i'm too good
for it i just uh time
uh have you seen the movie everything
everywhere all at once it is not playing
anywhere near me
oh the audio's echoey [ __ ]
hang on
ah screw it
okay and how about now
slap on the headphones and give up on
the mic if it's gonna be dumb
ah sorry for all the audio problems this
time around
better still oh i still like oe now it's
worse oh
crap
um
[Music]
oh
what about now
am i still echoing
now
so
folks let me know
or if uh
or if it's still bad
i guess i should talk a little bit more
wait sound is now it sounds difficult no
i ah god okay hold on slow down slow
down
okay i'm getting told literally
everything
oh
[ __ ]
and what about now
how does it sound to folks
now
hopefully
that will finally sort it
perfect perfect good it's all good it's
all good okay
all right looks like the initial
problem was that i had a secondary mic
picking up somewhere i don't even know
what
heck device that was but there was an
auxiliary mic that was picking something
up somewhere as well
don't know what the hell the issue was
okay
aside from alien three in the curious
case of benjamin button is the one film
in fincher's filmography which i have no
clue why he wanted to make it
i kind of just grew i kind of outgrew
fincher like i liked him more when i was
like in college and i thought like being
being that dark and serious was cool and
at this point i'm like no he's perfectly
talented filmmaker i just i don't care
uh what is this a verizon hashtag can
you hear me now oh boy that's a date of
reference
uh possibly an inbuilt mic yeah i'm
assuming so i just don't know what
device it was on
do i like cappuccinos is it
more likely to go for a latte
uh
have i seen mitchell versus the machines
nope heard it's great would like to see
it have not had the time
uh
this was brought up ages ago but one of
my shows celebrated its 10 000th episode
a couple years ago if we're competing
what there was one hang on i'm gonna
check something here
um
there was a show let's see
i know how long it was on how many
episodes oh fewer than i thought
3249 oh but that's just the show
what was it prior to hang on
so there there was um
like it's not going to hit 10 000 so you
still win but
um there was
and like
scripted show
because if you count it as a show like
plenty of nightly news shows have hit
that
um but what i'm just checking now is
there's a um
or there was there was a
um
[Music]
soap opera
uh called guiding light
and it started out originally
as a radio show
um
from
the through the 30s and the 40s
so it was a show that for a while was
actually older than television
um i don't know how many episodes it had
on the radio though
i can't find a number on that yeah but
it ran for it ran for about a decade
over a day ran for 12 years on radio
before it
became um
a tv show and then it ran for like
50 some odd years on tv
uh you need to try london fog oh i love
london fog i actually had one a couple
weeks ago liz picked it up for me it was
lovely
fun fact donald schwarzenegger was
originally dr octopus citation needed
genuine question what advice do you have
to someone in their 20s today
uh
um
you got to give me more to work with
than that
like someone in their 20s and
advice about
if you're just asking me general life
advice in your 20s i don't know
i'm twice that age and i was a disaster
in my 20s
uh
speaking of lattes anyone besides me
ever read legends and lattes haven't
heard of it but i like the alliteration
my mom watched guiding life from late
60s till it ended in the early 2000s
best mcbainline from the simpsons
oh i'm trying to remember
main thing i remember is just him
uh oh okay so
there's like the the board meeting
and the villains like any other new
business and he he enters rooms like
only your deaths
i also liked his screaming out to this
guy mendoza
[Music]
who wasn't a disaster in their 20s i
don't know but
i'm not here i'm not here to compete on
the disaster 20s
competition but i think i'd probably
place
supreme omega
thank you very much for the super chat
as classic as gwen's death do you feel
it had a negative effect on spidey
because part of the reason why she died
was to prevent peter from aging too much
um actually no i think the reason
for killing her was a little cynical
but i don't
think that
um
the actual impact on the character was
negative i think honestly
if the writers weren't willing to go
for marriage and long-term
commitment yet which they would
eventually later explore with mary jane
then there really wasn't a lot to do
with gwen
it's one of those cases where
there were more story possibilities that
would result from the fallout of her
death than from keeping her around and
you know i
i don't mean to talk that callously
about a character but it is ultimately a
character from a strictly narrative
perspective and not talking about her
like she's a real human being
um
she did more for the story with her
death than if she'd continued to live
continuing to live she was just another
peter girlfriend she wasn't even his
first girlfriend
so
hello i'm troy mcclure you might
remember me from such informational
videos as mothballing your battleship
and dig your own grave and save
i'll be turning 25 at the end of the
month well enjoy the disaster years
what's your advice for being in the 30s
um be kind to your knees
hate spider clones of the oh well the
clones i know the clones technically
started in the 70s the clones are a 90s
problem
by and large
uh who do i want to play the next doctor
i never have an answer for that i mean i
wanted to be joe martin it won't be and
i don't really have a pick beyond that
headed out meg okay it was good to see
you bye
can't stay for long going to london
early tomorrow for time fracture oh well
enjoy
scripted but a prime time soap opera
don't know if that's cheating
no that's not cheating do i have a
favorite character from south park
uh no
i don't give a crap about south park i
haven't in a long time and even when i
did watch it i didn't
like love any character i just used to
appreciate the writing
uh how long does spidey actually try
until sony actually tries the spidey's
clones film um
well they don't need to now that they're
dipping into multiverse stuff
you know are and have
chris farley versus phil hartman phil
hartman i'm i'm sorry
um i never thought chris farley was very
funny
you know even like his whole iconic
uh i live in a van down by the river i
never thought it was that funny i just i
it was just loud
there's certain comedians whose brand
seems to be volume
and
it generally either never connected with
me or it used to and it doesn't now like
i again i grew out of
it do i like joan rivers
as long as the next doctor isn't david
tennant again okay yes agreed on that
um
oh jojo lopez thank you so very much
it's very generous you and others like
jxc thought slime and philosophy tube
nerdy creators who came out as strands
helped me discover my own transness i
like to say you are awesome inspiring
thanks for being you oh thank you jojo
and and i'm
really happy that you are
you know coming to a better
understanding of yourself that's
always a wonderful thing for anyone who
can get to experience that
i may have already asked this but is
there a movie or tv show everyone hates
that you like
um
probably
i'm drawing a blank at the moment though
i mean the main one i can think of is
like i really i did i still do i really
like the first gi joe movies gui joe the
rise of cobra
uh the first live action gi joe movie
but part of the reason i like it is
because i'm not actually a fan of gi joe
like gi joe fans hated that because it
didn't take it seriously like the
cartoon and the toys were stupid there's
no reason to take it seriously it was
good fun
if they laugh that hard when i say a
joke they laugh twice as hard when i
yell the joke yeah there's yeah there
were a few of those especially in the
80s and into the 90s
how many requests do you have backed up
if i requested how many things will i
have to go through first i have several
things i may want to request i'm on the
fence all
depends on what it is
so
um
so if it is a movie
or like a couple of episodes of a tv
show
basically something that i could watch
in
two hours or less
you're probably looking at a couple of
months
say three to four
if it's a book
uh you're probably looking at closer to
a year
and if you're one of those mad people
who commissions me for an entire season
of season of television you're also
probably looking at about a year
um
those are the those are the most backed
up not because there's the most of them
but because they take the longest
still waiting for will ferrell to come
back to snl for one final jeopardy
sketch with alex trebek
and sean connery at the pearly case
that'd be a good sketch
when i first started watching you i had
no idea i was trans watching you for
some time and realizing you were trans
as well was great to find out oh
that's lovely
uh
adding on to
dallas bearing will we get another drunk
review for sonic 2 probably not
um
just i i don't think there's going to be
much new for me to say and i don't have
enough investment in sonic as a thing
like i don't like honestly there
probably won't be another drunk review
or at least i'm not planning on another
drunk review unless somebody
specifically commissions me one which
has happened i've had a couple of
reviews specifically commissioned as
drunk reviews
oh discord thank you carowind thank you
thank you thank you
all right um let me pull that up
all right so i'm currently not looking
at the chat
on youtube i am addressing questions
that have been asked in the
council of geeks discord server
um which is a patreon perk patreon.com
council of geeks
excuse me
the new hair looks fabulous thank you
i'm afraid i never make your live
streams as i'm in the uk but i have a
question i'm wondering if you've ever
read storm constantine i was so into her
novels as a teenager really should have
tipped me off that i'm not cis would
love to know what you think of them if
you're familiar i am unfortunately not
familiar so
i don't have uh any more answer to give
on that i feel like i've heard that name
before
[Music]
i don't know i don't know
the work uh at all
ahead of your saturday vid on uh
on chibnall which yes so spoiler there
the patriot the patreon supporters have
already seen it um but saturday's video
is going to be on chibnall um looking
for positives uh the first is that the
cinematography is often really good yeah
the show has looked great i'm not sure
how much credit chibnall himself should
get for that because that would largely
come down to the
directing team and i don't know
i don't know if the showrunner has a lot
of control over the directing hires i
don't know how it works it's i've always
understood show runners especially in
the uk to be largely framed as head
writer
um so i don't know how much influence he
actually had on the visual in terms of
like how good the cinematography was
which it was very good
do you think the fact that chibnall will
be the first producer since graham
williams to have only worked with a
single doctor impacts how we can judge
his tenure and that it takes to focus
off what works and doesn't and does not
work with 13 herself
um
yeah it does impact the conversation
because now we can't talk about one
without talking about the other
um because with someone like say moffatt
or um well it'll especially be true with
davis uh once he comes back and does
more but like let's just take moffat for
example he did
two doctors
and given the differences with them
and you know you can see the
consistencies in the writing
that he did from one doctor to the other
you can also see what changed so it's
like you can feel the influence of the
new performer and the new
characterization versus what stays the
same and what is definitely just
uh a moffat thing chipnel and whitaker
like it's it's too closely linked it's
hard to know
how much did her performance influence
the writing did it at all
we don't know because we never
would know how he would run another
uh another doctor
i'm not well today so may not make it to
stream
uh what was one aspect of rtd's writing
that you were looking forward to having
back plus any guest stars you'd like to
see
in the bbc centenary special like
there's already a million freaking guest
stars they've confirmed i wouldn't
actually actively not want to add more
uh to that
but uh as far as
rtd's writing i
it's hard for me to say because it's not
i'm not exactly
i'm not expecting or looking forward to
the idea that he would just be like how
he was before
so
like i'm i'm excited for
how he might handle things differently
with how he's grown as a writer so i
actually don't
really know how to answer that question
um
all right the oh
here we go
the logic of the supreme court used or
will use to reject roe could also be
used to reject loving versus virginia do
you think the american right is willing
to go after interracial marriage
yet
okay so
all right couple things about the
supreme court
the first thing
and everybody really needs to wrap their
heads around this
what was leaked
was a draft opinion
and more to the point it was a first
draft opinion
now
these have never been leaked publicly
before
ever
in the history of the supreme court
however we do know how they work because
once the final decision is made
earlier drafts become part of the
historical record they've never been in
the conversation aside from
um supreme court historians before
because again they never came out
ahead of an actual decision
so couple things to keep in mind about
this leaked um
draft
it does not guarantee
that the final draft will have the same
wording the same fundamental
rationale behind it the same scope it
may be very
it may be much much narrower in its
scope it does not even necessarily mean
that they are definitely going that way
there are decisions i can't cite you any
because i'm not uh
i'm not a supreme court historian but i
know they exist where first draft
opinions because that was what
whichever justice drafted it expected
the decision to be
they would on occasion
actually not be the final situation and
the final decision would be
the opposite outcome because
arguments made in front of in front of
the court arguments made between the
judges amongst each other swayed
opinions so that that was no longer the
majority opinion and the draft went from
being the majority opinion draft to
being a dissenting draft that has
actually happened
that having been said i don't want me i
don't want anyone to think that i'm
throwing you a bone and saying have hope
maybe it'll be okay i don't think it'll
be okay
this is part of why i don't want to
dwell on this topic too much because i
am
exceedingly pessimistic
about all this
however i do think it's important to
realize what is and is not the case
the decision is not final
what we have is a draft for what
one
justice
wants on paper
if this is the way that it goes is it an
indication that it's probably going that
way yes honestly it is but first of all
given the size and the scope and the
momentousness of this particular
decision if it gets written up at all i
would bet you it's probably going to be
robert's writing up not a leto so
there's that too
but
yeah i i have not dug exceptionally deep
into the quote unquote logic of the
draft because i know it is a draft and
it's going to be even if the if the
final decision of the court more or less
lines up with what this draft says it is
a draft it's going to be changed revised
and the exact wording is not going to
match so it is not worth it to me
to get myself worked up and get into an
even more negative headspace than i
already am by digging through something
that i know is going to change and i
don't mean changes in the outcome will
not be the same but i mean changes in
the wording i don't need to start to try
and parse the specifics of the wording
of something that the the specific
wording is guaranteed to change if not
the heart of the thing
um
there were additional questions in
regards to this i understand
your kid is a girl she is
uh what does it feel like raising
an assigned female birth kid in a
country where women's rights are so
threatened it's [ __ ] depressing
and i don't have
anything else to say to that it's
it is deeply depressing that's what it
is
some i think this is the last question
in regards to this
something i find
uh interesting about the us is your
popular culture keeps getting more
progressive but your politics keeps
shifting to the right because of how
undemocratic your political system is
i often wonder if those two things will
come into conflict at some point like
suppose at some point gop managed to rig
this uh the system sufficiently that
they effectively have permanent rule
will they say to disney you know it's in
your financial issues to make cartoons
where queer um
we're queer clear
cartoons with queer characters because
your audience wants it but we won't
allow you to produce shows in the us if
you keep doing that well they're already
trying to do that that's what's going on
right now in florida
with the governor there who's trying to
punish disney
for speaking out against his
state's anti-queer legislation so
they've already tipped like
what
what this
entire year in the political scope of
the united states
reveals and needs to reveal and people
need to understand
is that this is mask off
for the republican party
if you look at what they either have
passed or are trying to pass
they aren't
tiptoeing anymore
they are saying the they are saying the
quiet parts out loud you have states
where they are not only trying to remove
gender affirming treatment from
teenagers they are trying to remove it
for anyone under the age of 25 and if
they can get that why would they stop
there next step is to illegalize gender
affirming
medical treatment of any kind for
anybody they've even stepped outside of
the realms of we're protecting kids
because it was a smoke screen and it
always was you have states that are
criminalizing the idea that uh someone
would leave the state for gender
affirming care because it's not about we
don't approve of it and don't want it in
this state it's we don't want you to do
we don't want you to exist is what they
are saying and in the case of florida
desantis is saying flat out
you
do not have the right to say whatever
you want because it doesn't align with
the polit with the political landscape
that i have laid down and i will now
punish you for it
they're not pretending anymore
they've stopped pretending
that they aren't going to do these
things eventually they are doing them
now or they're trying to and i skipped
over the part of the question earlier
about the loving decision
would i think they would go after
interracial marriage yes
i think
that if
this decision
comes through the supreme court which i
expect it to and it strikes down roe v
wade
or especially if it completely wipes out
roe v wade
then the next target
is
national ban on transafirming care
for
anyone under 18
and then after that it will be
banning
gender affirming care for anyone and
then after that it'll be overturning the
um right to marry for same-sex couples
and then after that it'll be overturning
the loving decision
and no i should be clear i'm not saying
this is what every conservative wants
but this is what the people who are
currently steering
the ship want
this
we are in
what is rapidly approaching a worst case
scenario not just for this country but
for the world as a whole because as all
of this is going on
the planet is cooking
itself to death and it is our fault
and we're not only
not trying to fix it we're not even
stopping actively causing it
and it's not because not enough people
want to do it
most people on this planet
want to fix these things most people in
this country do not want these rights
stripped away
but it doesn't matter
because the framework set down by the
founding fathers which was intended to
ensure
that the the political minority still
maintained a voice
has been twisted and warped so that the
political minority now rules
which is the literal opposite of what
was supposed to happen
i said i wouldn't get too depressing
but there we go
i hope you get to that culture novel
before the midterms because i'd be very
yeah it'll be very depressed after
that is that not likely i will i will
try i'll try to get to it before the
midterms i i need to finish up the
discworld book i'm on right now
um we'll see
uh captain omni arrived at last to
brighten things up i come with a query
in the golden age 1940 to 1955 captain
marvel aka shazam was the most popular
superhero in the world more well-known
than superman do you think we would ever
see that level of popularity for the
character again
i
doubt it simply because
the thing was at the time he was
ubiquitous within comics
but no single no no single character
at this point in time is ever going to
exceed or become more
um
ubiquitous
uh in regards to
um
you know uh holding the culture as a
whole because there's too many
characters
shazam is beloved by the people who love
him if that will never be the majority
again i'm sorry i did miss a couple of
questions sorry about that bookworm i
have i heard of or played fallout new
vegas what did i think of it i played a
couple of hours of it and then got
motion sick so it seemed really neat up
until then except part of the reason i
got motion sick was i started getting
lost which is that's a compounding
problem with me in 3d games i get lost
really easily and in the process of
looking around trying to figure out who
i am and
not who i am where i am and swinging the
camera around i get motion sick
so
i tried it
started out okay
if i could not if it could not make me
want to throw up i probably might have
even enjoyed it
uh
so
all right i think
that'll just about rob guiding light ran
from oh this is the the soap opera i
mentioned before ran from january uh
1937
to september 2009 it's time on tv
overlapped with its radio run
um yep
from june 1952 to june 1956 oh they were
both running
and fun note the uh the person who asked
the questions around the supreme court
which i knew was gonna show up sooner or
later it ended up being the tail end of
the stream but i knew that was gonna
come up sooner or later
uh offered up a picture of their dog
which is much appreciated
ah
it's a fun game in my opinion sorry
about your motion sickness i am too like
i tell people that and they're like oh
well try this game like this one will
probably not get no they all give me
motion sickness the difference is some
do it a hell of a lot faster than others
that's basically how it comes down all
right i see there's people still
chatting and still typing out in the
discord i need to get back to the to the
regular stream so like you've got
you've got until i finish this beverage
to
send whatever it is you're typing
um and then i will address it and then
i'll come back to the main chat okay
is that all of it
oh
no tiny bit left
oh shoot sorry got a little of my water
on the keyboard
there we go didn't get between the
cracks ah
power girl or super girl which is better
in your opinion i like both but prefer
power girl
depends on who's writing them uh
honestly i think in general i like power
girl a little better but i do like
supergirl
i don't think they'll ban gender form
and care but will you leave the country
if they do i don't know and i don't want
to have to think about that possibility
right now so forgive me for
uh
bypassing that uh at this point
all right
back in the main chat okay
we go
so
what's your comfort song mine is cry
little sister that's an interesting
comfort song i do love that song
interesting as a comfort one
um is it the thing is my comfort songs
tend to
be a moving target they tend to not stay
the same forever i'll tell you
[Music]
um
one that stuck around that like nobody
knows
i really like moths
by jeff throw tulle
i really like that song a lot
i should give that one a listen again
actually
i heard the jessica hines as nest doctor
like
no but like i don't believe it so
do you think uh i'm gonna wrap it up
soon folks but let's see uh do you think
the
uh illumination mario movie will
possibly make the bob hoskins john
leguizamo version look better by
comparison
better no more inventive yes because i
expect the illumination mario to be
boring
uh
portal must have not done well with your
motion sickness yeah i only played
portal for about a half hour and it was
great
it was funny and clever and the puzzles
were interesting but like i had to stop
uh sorry i need another dog
i'll i'll be okay i appreciate that
though am i keeping up with picard doing
a video on it or has it not grabbed your
interest yet i have not had the time to
even start
like i don't
i know i say it a lot i don't think you
people realize
how backed up i am with stuff i really
don't think you understand
like it's bad
um and it's a lot of stuff
simultaneously
so yeah no i haven't even i haven't even
seen the first episode
so no
halcyon and on and on comes me to the
core oh that's a good one that's a good
pick i like
that i love living in the past by jethro
tall i actually don't know that way i
actually don't know that many jethro
tall songs but i know moths and i love
moths
oh captain omni snuck in there with a
super chat captain of the omni force
grants you their patronage thank you i
just discovered you had a patreon yes i
am that oblivious my bf gets annoyed by
it
you know what it can be endearing if you
know how to play it right
favorite bottle episode of a tv program
oh
[Music]
oh jeez i could i actually like could
make a video out of like best bottle
episodes at least of stuff i've seen
um
i'm gonna go with midnight from doctor
who
what if i wanted you to review half a
book
message me direct like email me or
contact me through patreon on that
because i i would have questions about
how that would work and i'd have to go
from there
um but if it's book related at all it's
still probably going to be a bit of a
wait of a while because i want to get to
the books that i've already been
commissioned to do
um
so
anyways i've already
uh i've been told by people in the past
that i'd given them anxiety when i
voiced my political concerns your
concerns are valid it's
just a draining topic
anyway that's it wrapping it up
thank you everybody for tuning in
i greatly appreciate it things did get
a little serious there but i figured
that they would
with
everything going on
anyway
thank you so very much for tuning in
i hope that you have a good rest of the
week
i hope that you take care of yourselves
take care of each other
and remember
you're beautiful
you are loved
you are valid
i know i did it in the wrong order this
time i don't care
you are the council
i'm just running the meeting
and until next time this council
is adjourned
my cavity